chances are that by now you've seen
plenty of Tesla's around and chances are
you haven't seen this one this is the
model s p90d the latest and very much
greatest version of the all-electric
sedan the ninety represents the 90
kilowatt hour battery pack an upgrade
over the 85 that'll let you go roughly
300 miles on a single charge the D is
for the dual motor setup one in back one
up front to apply power to all four
wheels that's great for driving through
snow and more importantly for
acceleration but what really sets this
car apart from the Tesla's you routinely
spot around the Bay Area is what Elon
Musk likes to call ludicrous mode
upgraded electronics which will cost you
an extra ten thousand dollars let the
car safely pull up to 1500 amps out of
the battery more power means more speed
in this case the ability to go from zero
to 60 miles an hour in 2.8 seconds
that's million-dollar Ferrari fast and a
sedan that weighs nearly 5,000 pounds